growing up is exciting there are so many  firsts to discover  your first word your first book  your first day of school  and with each new thing you learn you  grow  at khan academy we embrace and celebrate  learning at all ages  we created khan academy kids to spark  the joy of learning in kids ages 2  through 7.  through thousands of activities books  and videos  kids can read play  learn and grow  narrator cody bear and her friends guide  kids through the app encouraging  creativity curiosity and kindness  because we believe that everyone should  have access to learning khan academy  kids is completely free  no ads no subscriptions  khan academy kids now celebrating first  words through first grade available in  the app store google play and amazon